when it rains and water falls from the
sky it doesn't fall in one Continuous
Flow instead it falls in millions of
tiny individual droplets each happy
little droplet could be called a Quant
of rain where the word Quant means the
smallest unit that makes up a hole now
let your imagination wander to light it
too can be thought of as a shower of
light drops instead of a continuous flow
these individual bundles or Quant of
light are what we describing with
quantum physics we could also think
about splitting space itself up into
Quant if each little piece of SpaceTime
is like a grain of sand then together
they make up the beach of our universe
the inside of a black hole cannot be
squashed any further than the size of
the individual grains of SpaceTime this
is where Einstein's equations stop
working here space is distorted on the
quantum level